هي المنازله الاسبوعيه بينهما كالعاده
افتتحها زعيم وحزب العمال البريطاني
المعارض كريستيانو بابتسامه يليها هجوم حد
على سوناك فاستعمل اتهم الحكومه بانها
تدفع الاموال للذين لا يحتاجونها من
المدارس الخاصه مرورا بشركات النفط
العملاقه وصولا الى الاعفاءات الضريبيه
التي في رايه متوفره للاغنيه كما عرض على
سوناك بتهكم دعم حسبه حزب العمال في
مواجهه ما وصفهه بالتمرد بين النواب بحزب
المحافظين على زعيم بشان
لكن يمكنني انا مساعدته في هذا الامر فهو
لا يحتاج الى صفقه قذره اخرى اذا اراد
مواجهه التعديل الذي يطالب به النواب
المعادون للنمو او للناحيه تحقيق الهدف
الوطني
للقيام بذلك
وبين صيحات الاستهجان والتاييد التي تنتقل
بين جهات البرلمان بحسب هويه المتكلم لم
تكن ردود سوناك اقل حده خصوصا لناحيه
اتهامه
بانه لا يصلح لقياده البلاد
ومستخدما سلاح استعمل عينه ورده على
اتهامه بالضعف قال سمعت ان استعمل اضعف من
ان يمنع بعض نوابه من المشاركه في
الاعتصامات التي تدعو اليها النقابات وصفا
الحزب العمال بانه يكرر الافكار القديمه
نفسها انها نفس افكار حزب العمال القديمه
المزيد من الديون المزيد من التضخم المزيد
من الاضرابات يقول ما يريده حزمه ان يسمع
فينا اتخذ وانا القرارات الصعبه لهذا
البلد
هناك رفض مطالبه عمال البريد وقطاع
التمريض بزياده الاجور بنسبه تفوق معدلات
التضخم قائلا انها غير معقوله ولا يمكن
تمويلها وفي موضوع عبور المهاجرين عبر
القناه اكد انه سيفعل كل ما يلزم للسيطره
على الحدود وحمايه السياده هي المواجهه
الاسبوعيه الحميه كل اربعاء ياتي اليها
زعما الحكومه والمعارضه مجهزين بكافه
اسلحتهما ومصممين على الفوز بمعركه الراء
العام الذي ينتظر منهما كلام المقنعا
وحلولا لمشاكل البلاد فسناك وستمر يستدلان
اقتناءا بان نتائج الانتخابات المقبله بعد
عامين تصنع في جزء كبير منها هنا تحت قبه
هذا البرلمان العاريق عبد الحق العربيه